I mean maybe front would you drive
Inglewood California I was wearing suits
Anila Hospital okay so your yeah did you
ever believe that both parents no I had
I didn't have a mom growing up so it was
just me and my father I don't know on
drugs somewhere yeah it was good I had
to move to my mom's family's house so I
grew up with them
they were my grandparents so it was cool
growing up with them yeah I felt really
lonely with my dad so they took me in
and we didn't really we didn't really go
out to amusement parks and stuff like
that so they just took me in because
they had the money and they had the I
just went with them it was just a better
situation no
a little I mean I have a little issue I
think that he's doing stuff to my food I
think that he's spitting in my food so
that's the issue that we have right now
I moved back with him when I was like 20
22 23 so I don't know what he's doing to
my food but we got to talk about it and
set it hash it out for sure
yeah it was real good I didn't feel
lonely anymore
they they brought me up clothes shoes
anything I wanted I was a tomboy yeah
yeah brother sisters yeah I have one
autistic brother he has autism so I had
to help take care of him growing up so
it was cool
24
and yeah I went to see San Cal State
Northridge - then I dropped out I wasn't
really doing any work just smoking weed
so I dropped out
I moved in with my boyfriend it was a
tricky situation and I did some things I
regret so it wasn't really a good
situation so we broke up and I moved out
here on Skid Row well I kind of showed
him pictures of a girl in bed to get his
dick hard
so it wasn't good
it failed our relationship completely
yeah I was doing weed every day
yeah I do crack man yeah I'm a couple
years
[Music]
yeah I stayed with my dad in a
one-bedroom he sleeps on the floor I
sleep in the bed oh yeah yeah it's like
a studio it's like a studio apartment
I pass
yeah yeah I mean he doesn't say but I
know he's proud of me cuz I can't do
anything else yeah I can't I've tried I
tried working at Petsmart bond it just
doesn't work out I always make mistakes
a year now
you you writing yes okay
the supports on your
yeah yeah what do you charge for 30 like
20 to 30 dollars sometimes it depends on
who you are if you're real cute I don't
like your for five or ten you know what
I mean he I do that all the time
everything I do everything well I just
started having sex on the blade I call
it the blade
yeah so I just started having sex on the
blade before I just gave head we go to
Ali's it's real scary because I you know
I'm I feel like I'm dodging a murder so
it gets scary yes sometimes I have to
stop jobs in the middle of our session
just to stay safe
you're having Polish highlight $500 a
week I'm spending on crack crack is the
most expensive I do crack okay yep crack
is it expensive drugs to keep up for
real but I feel like it's one of the
best drugs every I've done every John
Chrystal we speed I've done every drug
heroin no I never done heroin I need to
do I need to try after I get off crack
but recently the son unorthodox herself
to me basically she's giving me an
ultimatum I gotta get our crack or I'm
gonna get murdered because I'm getting
extra good horny from the government so
they kind of they patrol what I do I get
extra horn good horny so you come to me
in session with me and prostitute and
help help my business you get extra
horny you get more hornier than you
would with another prostitute yeah yeah
so they governing what I do is the
government yeah and the son decide yeah
the son
yes
we'll make me extra horny if I have sex
with you yes we do tonight
I'm just joking yeah so she wants me to
get off crack because it's too much
is she the same in the government
yeah all right well thank you so much
for talking to me I think I closed my
future um just to continue prostituting
so come check me out I'm a skier Oh whoo
all right thank you thank you